Theo dưới chức băng kênh Chức Kỳ của Mỹ, Vô dưới mấy trở hàng của hàng Uft tại thành phố Louisville.
Chio người mùi nắm mùi một. Nát hiện in nhất bình người thêm mạng và người một người khác bị thương trong đó có bác thành viên phía nguang.
Chứ mấy bây mặt cho nào cho Clas MD 11.
Thì kiện chuyên bây từ Louisville đến Hauai, gặp nạn chỉ vai phố sau khi cất cáng từ sân bay của tệ mua mắt Ali.
Sự lợi chú thấy mấy bây nay đặt độ cao khoảng, nắm mấy bà mẹ chức khi mất kìm soát và lạo xuống.
Thì trường thành phố Louisville cho biết, gió lượng như liệu cho mấy bài còn lớn, nên người cơ tránh nổ rất cao.
Tên bôi hiện chương nửa bị phong toàn, đồng thời lạnh chua, tại chỗ vinh người dân cho bàn tính cảm kì lúc mẽ quân xin bay, đã được băng hàng.
Ui bán an tà dơ thông cuo xam nghĩ đã điều nhóm điều tra chuyên trách tử hiện chương, phối hợp người hẳng bốing, để làm soống mình nhân.
K video hiện chương cho thấy giấu hiệu cánh trái của mấy bây bốc trái, tạo ra một về khỏi sạch, chức K vỡ giới xuống và phán hồ.
Tên nhân quá trình và tế có thể kéo sai từ mấy hai đến hai mi tư tháng.